so you start freestyling right on the uh
on the street and that's where who will
save your soul came from yeah I wrote it
that whole trip so I take my change to
the office window the ticket station of
Amtrak and they'd give me a ticket for
maybe 20 miles down the road or
something wow and I'd get out and I made
it it's about three days to San Diego
and then I hitchhiked um from Tijuana
down to Cabo and then took a ferry to
the mainland side I took trains all
through the copper Canyons the copra de
Barrancas
and I just kept writing this song and it
got longer and longer and longer and
that ended up becoming wholesaver soul
I wasn't aware of you as an artist and
then I heard the song girl what is it
about it about that song is just
absolutely magnificent thank you oh my
God you're making me you're really good
about myself well you should well I
listen to the words Howard and I think
it's because you know it's a lot about
being in your head and what that can be
like yeah just like self-hatred yeah
acceptance absolutely you wrote that
about a girl who you had a fight with it
was just like a friend and it wasn't
supposed to be a song I was really just
bitching to my co-writers that day about
what was going on in my life and uh I
was just like I want to be friends with
this person like we're both in this
industry why can't we just root for each
other and not be competitive and
um and then I realized like a little bit
into it when it was becoming a song and
shaping up to be one I felt like no this
is about me I'm talking to myself and I
am really uh cracking you mean you're
talking to yourself about the that you
have a poor self-image or that you have
bad feelings inside just why am I taking
this so seriously this whole career
thing like this is supposed to be fun
and I was just really letting a lot of
criticism and pressure get to me and I
was maybe taking it out on this other
person and I realized it was really
self-reflective that's a pretty good
Revelation to have in your life to say
God I'm turning this into a nightmare
I'm like I'm starting to take my own
making I'm starting to take something I
love so much and making it so serious
that it's killing me inside and I'm
starting to become a drag right that was
that was it and I also like the
harmonies I didn't realize all of you
sing yeah that was great thanks do you
ever do an acapella I would love to hear
what your blend of your voices sound
like without music do you ever practice
it that way like when you first selected
you do and sound check sure yeah how
does that would you mind doing something
like that for me yeah all right
[Music]
um girl won't you stop your crying I
know that you're trying everything can I
be okay
baby girl don't you hang your head low
don't you lose your Halo everyone's
gonna be okay
baby girl
you were hanging out being a musician
and you were friends with Ethan Hawke
and he got uh was he directing a movie
he was in the movie Reality Bites right
Reality Bites the movie he was starring
in it Ben Stiller was the director Ben
Stiller was the director and he was in
it and Ethan asked me for a copy of one
of the songs that I was playing out at
my shows a lot called stay right and you
were just like an unsigned artist right
or somebody starting out with a musical
career yeah actually there were some
record companies interested in college
but they weren't quite well I wasn't
signed to a record deal okay so Ethan is
getting close it's a friend of hers
likes the song Stay and says to Ben
Stiller you put this on the soundtrack
for the movie Reality Bites when Ben
Stiller heard your song did he right
away say I've got to have this on my
soundtrack or was he like kind of like I
don't know I don't know I think he liked
it and because I wasn't signed any kind
of record company we were they were able
to make a deal with me to put the song
in the movie and put the entire song and
the credits of the movie and then all of
a sudden when the songs on the
soundtrack this way radio station down
in Houston
starts playing uh stay on the radio
and then other stations started playing
it and all of a sudden I was an unsigned
artist with a song going up the charts
and when my song was number one that's
when I was making my record deal this is
a song that holds up it's not it's it
holds up I mean it's still relevant
today yeah it's it's uh it's about
arguments with boyfriends so what was
this written about Ethan Hawke no it
wasn't written about anything this is
you trying to tell some guy to stay it's
that argument it's like you know you're
only here well the lyric is I only hear
what I want to and uh it's the argument
back and forth you know the person
saying you're naive you're this you're
that you're trying to be too clever he's
criticizing you and yet he's telling you
to stay yeah because but but that's what
happens in a strong relationship you
have to be able to argue I think I love
that story
people might not understand you being a
crack dealer but it seemed like in your
neighborhood this was some kind of
hustle well anything without proper
context you can judge someone totally
wrong so if you give given the
circumstances that we were in I'm not
saying we were good we we made horrible
decisions we're 16 years old right 14
years old we're going to make bad
decisions right yeah
decisions of life and death so we're
giving those proper contacts you can
probably you can see why a person could
make such horrible decisions I'm not
saying if we forgive us for a decision
just understand the circumstances and
not dismiss us as being just crack
dealers what kind of money is a 14 15
year old kid making dealing crack for
the most part no no money you could make
more money in McDonald's at the end of
the day if you
um add up the hours and you know you
can't wish it a good day good job right
not really you're standing out there all
day long
yeah you stood out there all day long
and you even say you avoided big prison
time you were in a car full of crack the
police had pulled you over right and
then all of a sudden
they were going to bring in dogs to
sniff out your car but the dogs weren't
available for some reason and they had
to let you go yeah that that's the
inspiration of 99 problems with a [ __ ]
ain't one right it's it's you know we
were talking about uh a K-9 on that
verse if you listen to Second verses it
all deals with that and it's even the
deeper underlining meaning to that stop
because
during that time the state she was
pulling people over for being black
driving while black right but they were
black guys and you know going up to you
know southern states with a trunk full
of trouble right so when we stopped and
when we meet at this point I'm getting
pulled over but I know I'm getting
pulled over nothing but I know I'm in
the wrong so now I'm having a
conversation with the cop as if I I'm
the cleanest guy on Wall Street and
we're having this conversation you're
having it's like this cat and mouse game
right you know with a person that's used
to getting away with it
versus this person who know he's in the
wrong but has these racial undertones
that's why there's there's this you know
I was doing 55 in the 54. it shows you
that I was being pulled over for nothing
yeah and obviously the speed limit is
55. it is an incredible mind [ __ ] when
you realize that you're being pulled
over because you're being racially
profiled right you didn't do anything
wrong but you in fact did do something
but you know you're wrong I'm so in the
wrong but I'm I'm speaking as if you
know but you you shut it in your book uh
and this really hit home for me you said
uh being born black is like uh being
born with the presumption of guilt right
like you always look guilty of something
right everyone thinks I've done
something bad here and I haven't but
meanwhile you had done something bad
well it makes you do bad things right
right sure because if everyone thinks
I'm guilty anyway why not go out and do
something bad yeah
when you write a great song like who
will save your soul um when you write a
song like that it comes out of your
misery in a way so like you're not
miserable anymore like it's almost I
never wrote miserable you know I wrote a
whole savior someone I was 16. I was
where were you at home hoboing well it's
interesting you know when I was 16 I got
a scholarship to a very prestigious fine
arts school
um the money I lacked I did a fundraiser
in my hometown and they helped raise the
money to send me to school which is
remarkable how nice is that amazing for
spring break you had to leave campus and
I couldn't afford
I didn't know you had to buy books I was
so ignorant I just showed up with the
tuition
nobody prepared you yeah or what school
yeah you have these two week spring
break and and I had nowhere to go with
no money and so I thought it was amazing
to me how here in the states all the
states are so close together in a matter
of hours you can be in a whole new state
right and so I thought I'd hobo by train
across the country to San Diego and I'd
hitchhike from Tijuana to Cabo and then
take a ferry to the mainland side of
Mexico and then isn't it amazing
adventure isn't it amazing that you you
and it's funny for an agoraphobic you
really got out there yeah it sounds
incredibly dangerous I got on the a
Greyhound from Traverse City to Detroit
I stepped sent the night in the Detroit
city bus station so that's a miracle in
itself and then got a on a train and I
made it to Chicago and that was my first
stop and my plan was to Street sing
except I didn't know anybody's music I
had just learned uh chords I learned a
minor C G and D right and uh I just
started making up lyrics my dad had
taught me to improvise as a kid and just
improvise about what was happening and
so I made up lyrics about people walking
by and it's my first time in a city my
first time seeing skyscrapers my first
time
seeing pop culture my first time I come
from a rural community it's very
grounded very down to earth and there
wasn't this worship of things television
and things and and wanting to be other
people and and so that's you know people
living their lives for you on TV they
wish they were better than you and you
agree right and just about wealth and
power and you love somebody of hearing
their will and so you start freestyling
right on the uh on the street and that's
where who will save your soul came from
yeah I wrote it that whole trip so I
take my change to the office window the
ticket station of Amtrak and they'd give
me a ticket for maybe 20 miles down the
road or something and I'd get out and I
made it it's about three days to San
Diego and then I hitchhiked um from
Tijuana down to Cabo and then took a
ferry to the mainland side I took trains
all through the copper Canyons the copra
de Broncos
and I just kept writing this song and it
got longer and longer and longer and
that ended up becoming wholesaver's home
I find the greatest bands are the ones
that don't sell out in other words you
could have changed your sound to a more
Commercial Sound you never did it and
that's why I think the audience is still
respond to you guys I agree completely
they see the honesty in what you do and
you know it's all relative someone we've
heard that we've sold out a million
forever right but it's all relative to
what your world is and if how small your
world is so we've we've we've stayed
honest to ourselves and that's all we
can that's all we can do when did the
sellout [ __ ] start when the Black
Album came out way before that ride the
light the lightning on the second album
we had a song called fate to Black that
we still play almost at every show and
um James thought it would be a great
idea to have acoustic guitars on the
album right so when the metal Community
heard a Metallica song with acoustic
guitars they all lost their [ __ ]
lunches big time this is the song you're
talking there you go the big sellout and
to me this is 29 years ago it is one of
the most beautiful songs out there
I mean wow what a song honest you know
well Fade to Black
[Music]
large said the writing of this song that
that James you were obsessed with death
that this was your death obsession is
that true uh still am somewhat I think
there's a fear of death that we all kind
of struggle with and battle with I think
at that point I remember writing Fade to
Black uh uh everything was metal Joe's
metal on metal Joe's couch
he took us in when our manager uh
basically kicked us out of his house and
over Jersey yeah over in Old Bridge New
Jersey 1983. yeah we lived out on his
farm and we just partied and played and
wrote songs and uh I think at that point
we were supposed to go we were supposed
to go to Europe for the first time
Twisted Sister yeah and our gear had
gotten stolen we got the phone call that
Not only was our well our our our our
then tour manager
had a U-Haul filled with our gear
someone stole a whole U-Haul doesn't get
more depressing than that when you're a
band and your gear is stolen you don't
have the money to replace it you can't
even play we were lucky that we we had
our guitars with us so it was so cold in
Boston that's where so now you can joke
about it but at that point you were so
depressed you had nowhere to live and
all your gear was stolen and then you
start thinking about Jesus what the hell
is life all about and we're gonna die
anyway more like our career is over
we're screwed we're you know and then
you come up with this yeah
kiss me chill
it's fantastic
what's the story on this song with the
you envisioned it with finger snapping
what was the story on that Dave the drum
pattern is really simple right Taylor do
the drum thing
so that's the basic drum track right and
then wait do it again you're not gonna
be able to hear this snap thing but go
for a tea
light one two three four
so then I like we and we recorded this
record in this funky old house right so
it wasn't a studio so we put a Kick Drum
and a snare like at the top of this
stairwell because the Reverb was cool
and then much like When the Levee Breaks
right and then wood there were wood
floors and so I was like oh wait let me
do this weird thing over it and then we
just started layering uh instruments
over it but not many the placement of
the drums really mattered because what
you got something acoustically out of
the drum yeah it sounded better at the
top of those stairs yeah because it
feels a simple it's a simple beat it's
got a lot of space so we wanted to get
the that When the Levee Breaks kind of
drums on and we didn't use a lot of mics
on the drums not to get too technical
but it was really all about that
stairwell sound like a big Echo
did you know the first time you record
wrecking ball that it's gonna be a huge
hit I bought it around to a bunch of
different producers in LA and all of
them were like slept on it everybody's
like no we don't need it we don't need
it I but I had shopped that around to
multiple people and they were like no we
don't need this one they didn't want to
produce it they didn't care about it
they just thought it was another another
ballad isn't that something and so some
people just have that ear and it's that
thing if what's meant to be is what
meant to be and then I I just knew
because that's what I was living at that
time that's what I was going through I
was going through that a big breakup and
everyone knew about it and you know what
I didn't hold anything back I went the
first time I performed the song live I
bawled and cried and my mascara was
running all down so this was about when
you sang it you were thinking about Liam
and you were thinking about it yeah I
was thinking just about I think that was
the first time maybe I'd ever really
felt hard I mean I've gone through
little breakups in your life but that
was a that was a really big that was my
only relationship that's really the only
relationship I been in that's real you
know and so that just it just I felt
that way when you sing that song now
when you go back to that place
I do when I record when I went but when
I made the video I had already kind of
like Band-Aid you know my heart all up
and I felt okay I pictured I had a dog
with the animals you're an animal lover
yeah I love it with animals um you know
so I I pictured my dog the whole time so
as emotional as it seems I was really
thinking about my Yorkie that I passed
away I wasn't really thinking about my
boyfriend at all
some guy wrote some book and he said
that in fact Uptown Girl wasn't about
Christy it's really about Al McPherson
this is what the guy came out with it I
don't know that you told him this they
didn't get the whole story they got part
of it uh right I think what they were
trying to do was debunk that it was all
about Christy I wasn't even dating
Christy when I started writing the song
I was writing L right and what a lineup
of women it was amazing it was just an
amazing time that's why I started
writing a song called Uptown Girls it
was plural I couldn't believe you know
the situation I was in I just I couldn't
believe this so you couldn't believe the
fact that you had met in one in one just
chance encounter you were there with
Christy Brinkley Al McPherson and
Whitney Houston The three of them were
swooning over you playing the piano or
something I don't know if they were
swooning they were there all right you
know they were standing over the piano I
was playing I looked up and there was
Christie Brinkley oh McPherson Whitney
Houston anyway I was I wasn't even
dating Christine when I started writing
this song and it was I don't remember
what the lyrics were but it was like
Uptown Girls and I've been all around
the world is is bad a lyric as the final
lyric was it was just corny is that is
it always the music was there already
but you were just trying to think I had
the music it was almost like a like a
classical piece
like a minuet yeah and then the left
what they call that the uh
uh something left hand
this is a classical term when you write
a song is that what you heard in your
head no no that's not what I heard I'm
just playing a piano arrangement of it I
heard like a Four Seasons thing
[Music]
you know one of those kind of songs so
go ahead so I was dating and then when
you blow that off and you say you're
dating L she is one of the hot I mean
her body is perfection true yes she was
called the body she was called the body
yes and for how long did that go on
a couple months we dated on and off it's
not like we were you know engaged or
anything we just kind of dated I can't
even imagine
leaving now McPherson I didn't leave her
she left you well she went to Europe she
was just starting on the modeling career
she had been in the states for a few
months we dated and then she went to
Europe I figured that was it you know
that's that's romantic that yeah and
then I I started to date Christy nobody
dumped anybody we just kind of went
different ways Johnson now McPherson get
mad at Christy for taking her boyfriend
no I wasn't really her boyfriend it was
never going to be that oh okay we kind
of knew that but did you had you
collected both their numbers on that
first night okay well not the first I
think uh I contacted Christy later on
down the road after L and I had stopped
dating oh okay and then I started dating
Christy and rather than it'd be about
all these different girls if she became
the Uptown Girl I started writing it
about one person so it is about Christy
yes oh because so they got the story
wrong I actually felt bad for Christy
when this came out because I said you
know a lot of Christy's identity is
being the Uptown Girl and being the one
who's in that video and being Billy
Joel's wife and so for this book to come
out and say oh it's really about Al
McPherson I bet she was brokenhearted to
hear that like I I think it probably
bothered her I don't know but I'm
assuming you can call her and say by the
way that's not true I want you to know
honey this is about you because I know
you still care about her you still you
have feelings we're still friends you're
still friends I think she knows what the
story is though I mean because we talked
about it a long time ago when this first
story came out but I had started writing
it when I was dating L that was the
story and that was it that's all it was
too it wasn't about L particularly
because it was originally called Uptown
Girls give me a little bit of it just
just for the hell of it I mean the
actual song a little bit a little bit
don't do the whole thing I'm not gonna
be able to do it let me drop the key
Uptown girl she been living in her
Uptown world I bet she never had a
Backstreet guy
it's supposed to sound like Frankie
Valli but it doesn't it's too early in
the morning that was your that was your
tribute to Frankie Valli but I I heard
it like you know what was that song he
was the rich guy and she was the poor
girl Ragdoll right
[Music]
and he's she's from the wrong side of
the tracks and he can't go out with her
and you know what the lyric in that song
is I love you just the way you were
[Music]